golden state warriors taking on the
brooklyn nets tonight and stephen curry
uh is kind enough to spend the next 25
minutes with us wow that's generous of
your time steph thank you
uh hey look by my count it's been 292
days since you played in an nba game
that actually
mattered chuck says there's no such
thing as
rust is there no we know how to put the
ball in the basket it's just a matter of
uh
getting your you know new faces
acclimated and whatnot
the only thing is it's obviously a
shorter training camp so different
experience for for everybody not just us
so
uh just trying to adjust on the fly and
uh
and have fun playing basketball again
like you said it's been a long time
since uh
we've been in that competition so i'm
excited steph this shack here you're
still my favorite player i will not be
abandoning you
um question uh you started from the
bottom made it to the top
went back to the bottom what's going to
take you guys to get back on top
like back in the old days like like in
the dynasty days
just falling in love with the chase i
mean um you know we do have a new cast
of characters and
but we still have that championship dna
myself draymond
i know what it takes to to play at that
level um
and trying to you know keep that culture
going so i think if we
you know play defense the way that we we
can play to our strengths
um you know and unlock some guys that
have a lot to prove this year in our
locker room we could surprise a lot of
people and
we we love all the different narratives
that uh that we've been in the last you
know five six seven years so
this is a different territory and uh
we're excited about the chase
you know steph you guys had the number
two pick in the draft you took mr
weissman from memphis how has he been
progressing he's been great man
i feel like uh i can't imagine for a
rookie coming in obviously second draft
pick
you know a short timeline of getting
adjusted nba basketball
missing most of the first you know part
of camp and then you know starting his
first regular season game that's a lot
to throw at somebody so
you know we're trying to bring him on
you know slowly bring him along slowly
but i think he has an
amazing potential to impact the game
right away and uh you know excited for
him this is a
going to be a memorable night for him
just to be playing nba basketball
starting his
his first game and and uh you know the
start of a long
amazing career hopefully so uh you know
we're excited to see it up close and
personal
steph you know you guys weren't in the
bubble
but i would imagine being in the bubble
and like
moving around and seeing players daily
on a daily basis kind of get your juices
flowing
i'm watching you right now that's an
eerie feeling there's no one behind you
if you were in a tunnel for game one of
a it would be
activity everywhere how are you guys
drumming up
in a big arena and not a bubble
situation how are you drumming up that
energy
we talk about it we have to you know
bring your own energy every night
i think it actually helps knowing that
uh the bench
and every other guys on the sideline
have to bring that as well so you can
kind of see a different dynamic
you know during the game because you
know you make a good play or
you go on a little run the only people
that are cheering for you are your guys
on the bench
so i think that adds a different element
to it so you gotta
really lean into that um but in the day
what i've noticed you know pre-season
all that once you actually get you know
you're on the court and running up and
down and playing you don't really
realize
um the timeouts are different but at the
end of the day we just gotta you know
bring out an energy
compete you know try to start off games
you know
on a good note and see where it goes
about 90 minutes from now steph you're
going to tip this game off you're going
to look across the court and see kevin
durant there what's that going to be
like
it's going to be weird but it's going to
be great um obviously what he's been
through with his injury and
you know you want to see every guy
especially at the top of the league
you know healthy and playing basketball
so i have a smile on my face to see that
and then once the ball tips it's
it's competing i think we all understand
what that level is like
and when you play against great guys
like him kyrie they bring the best out
of you so i'm excited to be back in that
in that fight and uh you know familiar
face that you know we went to war for
three years together
uh accomplished a lot and i think we all
know we both got a lot left in the take
so
um it's gonna be fun to uh to compete
like that again with a guy that you you
know pretty well
so is you and draymond on the court but
without clay what's the true expectation
for this team
i mean we know uh what the experts are
saying and what uh
you know where people kind of see us in
the western conference but um
you know for us it's got to be a
situation about how the season starts to
understand we're going to get better you
know every single game every single week
you know we obviously want to be a
playoff team and
and once we get in there uh we know
we'll be a tough out so
um you know the beauty of it is every
game is important
uh you know win or lose every game is an
opportunity to learn and bring the young
guys along and
i think we understand that so we feel
like we're a playoff team we're gonna
get there and
you know this will be a fun 72 game
journey
last thing steph when's the next time
you and chuck are going to get on the
golf course together
i was waiting for you to bring that up
man i can't get i just can't get that
memory out of my head i appreciate y'all
distracting for a whole hole so at least
we got we won that one but
uh yeah that line uh could he surprise
you
oh chug one well i know he surprised you
with this game
yeah i was on the range and i knew we
were in trouble because uh he was
striping on the range and his swing was
was definitely different
the best part about i guess was his
putting i i didn't really realize he had
that in him so
he uh he showed some touch uh you know
his partner wasn't bad either
dude anything truck no that was that was
i want to thank you
and phil and peyton for giving up the
thanksgiving with your family man we
raised a ton of money for
historically black colleges and that's a
sacrifice i mean
thanksgiving is awesome but you guys
gave that up so thank you brother for
participating i absolutely appreciate
you uh you're kicking our butt
i'm gonna try to do that to brooklyn
right now i'll see y'all i like it i
like
it i told you it almost was 25 minutes
thank you steph curry joining us
from barclays uh in brooklyn i watched
the match you didn't do
much yeah you didn't do a lot i watched
her still ain't beating me yet
chuckster i got your back thank you
ernie i like the swing okay
first of all you don't like in a swing
that's like i like your form but doesn't
mean no
scott goes in no but from where his
swing was to where it is now
yeah playing with phil you're playing
with the probably
the if not the top three golfer of all
time
and against two guys who are not pros
like
from a guy who showed up for persimmon
woods that was
10 years ago
he came to play in my chair of the golf
tournament 10 years ago yeah it was more
than that
he don't even play golf he grabbed golf
clubs out of him somebody made somebody
shows up
on the range it brings up and i still
drove them over there
shaq i don't know that is that they're
like real woods
yeah yeah it'd be like you driving a 59
chevy right now
like it was like a mercedes-benz well if
i put some things on that thing